i did want to ask you a little bit about
the ending of the show and specifically
i mean you you know the talk that's been
about that ending you know it's divisive
some fans like it some fans don't like
it when they don't like it they really
don't like it but
how is it from your perspective as an
actor in the show
who isn't responsible for the writing
how how do you kind of
deal with that intense fan base and
you know kind of i don't know embrace
how you feel about the ending but also
respect the other side of it that's been
invested since day one
i appreciate both sides i got a little
bit of an insight into why
they did what they did uh i mean from
memory gosh it was a long time ago but
it was
it was just sort of about having having
dexter have nobody and that that was
that was kind of the ultimate um jail
in a way for him to to not have anybody
left um and then you know and then i get
i get the fans as well i get that
perhaps it wasn't sort of the most
dramatic ending that they had longed for
um maybe they wanted to see more blood
and gore um
you know but i think you've nailed it
it's um it's not my responsibility
so so it doesn't really bother me
whether
you know whether people liked it or not
it's um it's just something that that i
was a part of
you